okay so let's try to play a game and
please better than the ones before the
last four games you're really about the
worst I've ever played and this era but
I can remember it was absolutely
atrocious ok we are miodrag yes teaches
the opponent yeah thankfully i get a
physician assistants traded so at least
I'm getting not getting checkmated with
some silly thing and okay so this is a
slightly better ending voyage just slide
him each for h6 insert it is pretty nice
that air loader then end game has been
played a lot in there in the 70s and 80s
without h4h 6 included and include
although including those moves as a
slight accomplishment for white because
I'm black has the scale weakness there
so let's see how this goes it's not in
much of course but given the choice I
think white is slightly slightly
preferable
let's see a porn ever I cannot take but
it's still something that yeah this is a
well-known motif the night now is a
little bit better than the bishop in
there in the ending okay so let's play
this ending against the band bishop i
won their King c6 and b5 and that could
be an idea for him to get rid of one
down one weakness there maybe I should
start with this movie I introduce the
night at 5am and now add this b5
business lipton it's not so nice that he
gets rid of this this pawn on a dark
square right okay
ok
[Music]
blam make some headway against this we
have to play this it looks a bit strange
put it on dark squares but with
therefore i think i need to gain some
space right against any to gain some
space it's really really necessary
so we put everything on light squeeze
that you can now that that is certainly
make some sense so f 5 i'm heading now
f6 and 95 wins f7 okay
key for and then again I'm f this F 6
idea it's probably not yeah well maybe
f6 can you [ __ ] at 595 and I win this
pawn it could work King see 595 attacks
the porn and threatens 97 still goes
down
so i take this i have f 6 as well f6
Bishop takes Knight f7 check King takes
Knight takes f6 it should win it should
we
yes to hesitate basically Wow
wow ok ok
black resigns yeah it was the game that
I need a jump something really really
simple way I don't get shaken me to talk
and blunder stuff oh my okay um yeah so
there's nothing much I understand there
but this is it is slightly more
convenient ascending okay I'm really
happy to trade this one that's fine yeah
it's equal issue of course but here I'm
quite happy to get to this position this
move this this and now the engine is
maybe a ride em it's promet be better to
not trade to trade hooks because he had
this King up to c6 mp5 I think that
actually equalizes the black the engines
suggestion to play g3 and f4 looks
pretty good the thing is his Bishop is
currently not the best piece ever and
with g3 f1 planning to open up on the
King sign that that's a bit better for
white for real yeah yeah I didn't really
realize that he is able to get rid of
this weakness on the on the queenside
can hear you shouldn't lose any more
that that should be equal yeah g3 f form
is kind of can can we can be debated but
I didn't really see how to make any
headway without it and he at least there
are some level things going on so c4 ok
and now in keeney for and f6 so Bishop
b2 else is already not quite trivial to
give up h6 this Sofia was was already
very very
problematic yeah the engine basic this
has wide wings no it's probably true
that was making it easy but ok this is
awesome of course winning so the saving
move was there should be two then giving
up that on and if i go here he teaches
that and this looks extremely ugly but
may catch probably defensive i am so
here can i what can I do I mean what
what happens here so kini five okay yeah
this this 98 okay that's easy for
computer here to see that this is this
is draw okay it's not not so trivial at
all to see from the from the beginning
here I mean the dead that just doesn't
work out thinking and the ending
confirms okay thanks guys